Dave rubin report,
I've been really inspired by the
reaction to the interview with Sam.
I knew that I felt really passionately
about the issues we talked about and
needed to address the campaign to
discredit him and I knew a lot of other
people felt the same way,
but I think I actually underestimated
just how badly people wanted this
conversation to happen,
from Youtube comments to the tweets to
people who wrote me literally pages of
thoughts on facebook and email.
There was a real sense that it was
cathartic for people who were feeling
the same thing I was.
That's exactly what I want this show to
be,
so I'm really proud that we got off to
the right start.
If we're going to build some kind of
community here based on the principles
that I laid out last week and put an
action in the interview with Sam.
I think I have to ask something of you
now.
Many of you were giving me Kudos for
having an honest dialog,
but if we really want to change things,
it's going to have to be way bigger than
just me.
I'm sure some of you know that I'm gay.
Actually.
I got gay married two weeks ago,
which is pretty gay.
It's pretty much the gayest thing you
can do.
I don't really bring it up anymore
unless it's related to something in the
news and I don't want any extra credit
for it or anything like that.
We got a quality.
There's still work to do,
uh,
but we've done great things that are
moving forward.
That's how progress is supposed to work.
A couple of years ago,
I hosted a podcast and a Sirius xm show
called the six pack.
It was a pop culture,
a new show with celebrity guests aimed
at the lgbt community.
The show was really different than most
gay culture out there and that it was
hosted by two guys who just happened to
be gay,
but we didn't make everything about
being gay.
I mentioned this because we used to get
a ton of email from people saying how
much we were helping them come to terms
with themselves.
Come out of the closet,
talk to friends and family and all that
stuff.
Even more than that though,
we got a ton of email from people saying
they were still closeted and our show
was there only gay outlet one day.
This strange paradox hit me,
the people that we were helping the most
by doing the show,
the people who are closeted and had no
other outlet where the same people who
helped us as a show the least and that
they couldn't tweet about us or share
posts about us on facebook or even tell
their friends about us.
I really struggled with this in my
relationship to the audience because I
knew that closeted life all too well and
I know that if the situation had been
reversed,
I would have been one of those people.
Like I said before,
I think we're onto something really
special here.
We're going to be part of something that
takes back liberalism for true liberals,
but to do that we have to be louder.
We have to be braver and bolder to save
what we think and share it with the
people we know.
I noticed a lot of the people with the
word atheism in their usernames have
anonymous profiles on twitter and some
even on facebook.
We all have our reasons,
and I'm not passing judgment on anyone
here,
but think about that for a woman in 2015
atheists are one of the last groups of
people that feel like they have to be
anonymous when they say what they really
feel.
Again,
this isn't everybody or even the
majority,
but it seems to be a bigger portion than
it should be and believe me,
I get it.
I was closeted for a long time.
You might have family that won't accept
you as an atheist or maybe your
community won't or maybe you aren't
fully sure what you are.
I don't want to make this just about
atheists though.
I think all of us secular people have to
be seen and heard more.
Let's not just talk about it with each
other.
Let's get other people in on the
conversation too.
We don't need to go out and find
converts.
They'll find us because that's what
humanism and secular realism does.
By default,
we just have to be louder.
It's not going to be easy.
All three of the people who sam and I
talked about who continuously
misrepresented him,
I've done so again publicly since our
interview.
Feel free to check out my twitter feed
to see the latest nonsense.
These people are simply not going to
stop.
If we want to be heard,
we have to clearly fight back with logic
on our side,
so if you hear me,
if you dig what we've started here and
you wanted to get bigger and better than
like share,
comment,
post,
and do whatever the hell else there is.
The forces of anti-intellectualism and
radicalism are always on the march.
Let's get our voices heard so that we
can win not by violence,
but by ideas.
Remember,
as Obi wan said to luke,
the forest is what gives a jetta his
power.
It's an energy field created by all
living things.
It surrounds us and penetrates us.
It binds the galaxy together,
but if you don't post about it on
facebook,
nobody will know.
Carrie.
Santa Maria is the host and producer of
the talk,
nerdy podcast cohost of the skeptics
guide to the universe La area.
Emmy Award winning reporter for so cal
connected on Casey,
he t and science correspondent for tech
now on Al Jazeera America,
but most importantly she's my friend.
Kara,
welcome to the show.
Hey Man,
your resume is blowing up.
Huh?
Getting kind of crazy.
You got a lot of stuff going on.
All sciency stuff and you are my
sciencey girl.
I'm the Goto.
Yeah,
you are my go do.
So I thought you'd be a perfect second
guest to have on the show because you
know we had Sam Harris on last week.
Also.
Scientists also assigned.
Yeah.
It's actually like really a scientist.
I'm not really a scientist like Sam.
Is he more of a scientist?
He's a neuroscientist.
Yeah,
Sam.
Sam actually finished the Phd.
He took time off to write his first
book,
but then he actually went back and
finished.
I took time off and just kept taking
time off.
So I got the masters.
But you're my girl.
I know you.
Communicator
communicators.
That's where I wanted to start actually
because right under your name right now
it says science communicator.
So what is a science community?
Okay.
Do you know?
I think more than anything is just a
catch all term that a lot of people in
my profession you so it could mean that
you communicate science as an author,
maybe you're a blogger,
maybe you give talks,
maybe you do what I do,
which is more in front of the camera
work or even some production work behind
it.
So sometimes it takes a more
journalistic flare,
sometimes it takes more of an
entertainment flare and those are two
very different camps,
but it all falls within that science
communication umbrella.
I mean the main goal is to help
communicate scientific principles to the
public,
help improve science literacy and do a
little bit of translation because
sometimes scientists aren't very good at
liaising with the public.
Sometimes they're amazing and I love
that.
Sometimes they need a little bit of help
and so that's,
that's where people like I come in,
right?
And I think sometimes people on my side
of it,
I need help and that's why I always
bring you on to,
to clean up some of the scientific
message.
I'm better at English,
but you,
you helped me clean up some of that
stuff.
So obviously we,
some of our older audience that's going
to here have heard some of what we're
going to do here,
but we have a whole bunch of new people
that I think are going to really dig
this.
So I want to get to the science stuff
later,
but I wanna start with atheism because
you're also my main atheist.
You and Jacqueline Glenn are my two main
atheist.
Um,
so first off,
uh,
why don't we do some basic definitions
here?
This might be tough.
It's going to be tough.
I think you can handle the atheism.
Burse agnosticism.
Yeah.
So I mean,
technically agnosticism is,
if you just break down the word,
it's not knowing,
right?
A lot of people self identify as
agnostics.
If they say,
I'm not sure if there's a greater power,
I'm not sure what happens after you die.
And I don't want a hedge any bets.
Now.
I personally think that the label
agnostic is redundant because you know,
whether you're a theistic or theistic,
whether you're a believer or a
nonbeliever.
I said this backwards,
nobody knows if you claim to know,
like you're full of shit.
No,
you don't know things.
I don't know.
You don't have powers.
I don't have.
I don't.
The people who scream about out at the
most,
they usually seem to to know the least.
Yeah.
Actually,
there are some studies that confirm
that,
so.
So I think of myself as an agnostic or
I'm sorry,
an atheistic agnostic and some people
are theistic agnostics,
meaning that I don't factor God into my
daily life.
I simply do not believe that God exists.
Yeah.
But I don't know if you have morals,
if it's coming from somebody up.
There were two morals come from,
well,
how do we get,
have morals,
morals come to be a pretty moral person.
I'm pretty forthright person.
How do you.
That's very nice of you to say,
okay,
that's true,
but,
but how do you navigate the sort of
moral divide if you're not getting it
from,
from some old book with some numbers,
right?
Because I was raised Mormon too.
Let's not forget that we're getting to
that.
And then I left the church.
So not only,
I'm like more of a heathen,
I'm kind of the worst criminal within
the churches viewpoint because I
actually accepted Jesus was baptized and
then rejected it,
which is way worse than never having it
to begin with.
Right?
Um,
where do I get morals?
I get morals from literature,
I get morals from ethics courses,
I get morals from,
you know,
see I get morals from interacting with
people and looking at their struggles
and trying to put myself in people's
shoes and trying to understand the human
experience.
I mean,
we are innately empathetic creatures.
We are innately moral creatures and the
more that we can kind of embrace others,
the more that we can try to,
I think remove the US them paradigm,
which is also very human and it's also
very difficult to push past.
But the more that we do that,
I think the more that we can live these
moral lives.
And a lot of people want to say that
morality is sort of a,
um,
an outcome of religion.
Perhaps a religion is an outcome of
morality.
Sure,
there are correlations between the two.
But as I often say,
when we talk about science,
correlation does not imply causality.
There's no way to prove that without
religion we wouldn't have or that you
know,
that.
Yeah.
Without religion we wouldn't have a
moral compass.
And it's actually pretty philosophically
ludicrous to sink in those terms.
So.
Okay.
So you are from Texas,
as you just said,
you grew up Mormon.
So in the Mormon church,
when did you come out as atheist?
Yeah,
so if I'm remembering correctly,
I came out when I was around 15 years
old and it was like coming out.
I mean,
how did the idea of general care,
how did she feel about like actually
having to say this thing and that's the
thing.
I actually had to say it because I
wasn't,
I didn't grow up in kind of a sort of
religious household.
I grew up in a very traditional Mormon
household.
So I,
I remember telling my father I had been
questioning for awhile and he had been
given me kind of the pat responses of
like,
you know,
pray about it and whatever.
You'll figure it out on your own.
And when I would pray about it and
nothing would happen,
and then I was like,
what am I doing?
I finally remember telling my father,
you know,
I don't believe I don't believe,
and I feel like I'm lying myself going
to church every Sunday,
every Wednesday,
every day before school going to
seminary.
It was a huge part of my life and it
felt like a big ruse.
I think much like somebody who is in the
closet and who is struggling trying to
act straight or trying to be somebody
that they're not.
And so I remember telling him and I
remember these words,
as long as you live under my roof,
I have a moral obligation to God to
force you to go to church until you're
18 years old.
Wow.
So what do you do with that?
As a 15 year old,
I didn't live under his roof anymore.
So it was a big choice.
You know,
my parents had long been divorced and at
15 I remember saying to him,
you know,
technically I think I'm of an age of
consent where if we went to the
courthouse and I pled my case that a
judge would say she can stay with her
mom full time.
It's her choice.
She's,
you know,
she's old enough to make these kinds of
decisions.
And I was a pretty precocious kid.
I'm sure I could have convinced the
judge that I had thought about this
quite a bit,
which I had.
And so my father said,
okay,
he let me make that choice.
It was a difficult bind to be in and I
didn't talk to him for many years after
that.
Our relationship took a big hit and
yeah,
it took a long time for us to get back
on good terms.
So there's two really different but
interesting pieces to that because
there's the choice that you made in your
own life to say this is who I am,
but then there's this other piece of.
It's not easy for it,
for a 40 year old to say to their
parents,
I don't believe in what you believe,
much less a 15 year old.
Maybe it's even easier for 15 year old
because you're like rebellious at that
point anyway.
I mean,
I'm not sure,
but that definitely I look back at the
gravity of that decision and I think
like,
Whoa,
that was pretty bold of me.
Um,
I'm not sure if I felt that way at the
time.
How do you separate.
One of the things we talked Sam about
a lot with separating the doctrine of
something from the people that follow
it.
So in the case we,
Sam,
it was mostly about the doctrine of
Islam versus Muslim people.
So how do you now,
after the experience that you had with
your father believing what you believe
your whole career really is,
is very much based in this.
How do you separate the doctrine of
mormonism?
I'm sure you have many other family
members that you love that are great
people and all that.
How do you separate that from the piece
of you that says,
I just don't believe in any of this?
Yeah,
you know,
I think it's,
it's for me,
it's easy to separate for my own life,
right?
Like I can look at mormonism and I can
look at my beliefs and I can say that's
bullshit and I don't believe in it,
but of course there are people that I
love who are like hook,
line and sinker.
They buy into it and it's one thing to
step back and say,
you know,
they bought into bullshit,
but it's another thing to actually say
I'd still respect these people in there.
Well,
you know,
I don't come.
Yes,
I come from Texas.
I don't come from like rednecks.
You know,
my mother who is no longer more men,
is an educator.
She's a school teacher.
Recently retired.
My father,
who still is very much mormon,
is an engineer and his wife who was also
very much warman is a science teacher,
a very good science teacher.
And so these are educated people who
promote education and who are very good
parents adopted,
you know,
adult.
Not Adult,
but teenage children after we had moved
out of the house like incredible people
and I love them dearly,
but we have a big disconnect when it
comes to belief now.
I don't think they need to believe what
I believe for us to get along and vice
versa.
It's one thing when you're in a parental
child situation,
the rules are a bit different.
Um,
but it is still tough because I think
one of the things that you take with
you,
no matter how long after the
reconciliation happens,
is a bit of pity.
A bit of like,
I,
I know in my heart of hearts that I kind
of feel sorry that they lived this
lifestyle,
feel sorry for them,
that they're sort of enslaved to these
religious rules.
I feel sorry for them,
that they have to struggle with big
issues like accepting homosexuality in
the family,
for example,
and their church teaches them that this
is an abomination and it's so ingrained
in them.
But I know they must struggle feeling
like that,
but I love this person.
How could that person be an abomination?
Those I feel sorry for the,
the completely religiously inundated
that they have to do that
pity for you to like they would look at
you and go,
well,
she doesn't have these incredibly
powerful beliefs.
Oh Yeah,
my dad thinks I'm not going to heaven.
Like,
well,
yeah,
exactly.
And not especially not the celestial and
the terrestrial in heaven gets super
complicated in the Mormon faith.
But yeah,
of course you feel sorry for me.
He thinks I'm not going to bathe in
God's glory for all of eternity.
That's like a pretty big deal to
somebody who actually believes that
exist and you're not doing that
just as a private person.
You're doing it as well.
Oh,
very publicly
and interacting with a lot of people and
potentially influencing people and you
know,
it's um,
I'm a heretic and that's,
you know,
probably not something he's very proud
of.
Why do you think atheists are so hated?
I've seen poll after poll and we've
talked about them in some other shows
that atheists are the most distrusted
group in America.
Uh,
people would never vote for an atheist
to be president.
Um,
you know,
Barney frank,
who came,
who was a congressman from
Massachusetts,
a pretty liberal place,
came out as gay and something like 1983
didn't come out as an atheist until he
was on real time with Bill Maher after
he had retired.
And since then has even backtrack a
little bit on saying that he was an
atheist.
What is it about atheist because the
atheist that I know are pretty much by
and large,
the most decent sort of humanistic,
uh,
open people that I know and yet there's
this portrayal of them that's completely
true.
I don't think it's that people think
that atheists have horns or anything,
you know,
I,
I think there's,
there's racism and xenophobia and
there's hate and there's fear and
there's all of the different things that
feed into why people don't trust or
don't like what they don't understand.
I think specifically though with
atheists,
you have to put yourself in the shoes of
the religious to understand where this
hatred comes from because of course
nonreligious people don't have any
problem with religious people running
for office office.
It's religious people from.
Sorry,
nonreligious.
People don't have any problem with
atheists running for office.
It's religious people that have a
problem with that and think about,
okay,
so for example,
you're an upstanding gay man and there
are moments when you have your moments
and there are some religious people who
think that you are just Yuck,
right?
Who think that like,
like being gay is disgusting like Edward
[inaudible] book because that's what the
Bible teaches and so they have these
ideas in their head that your lifestyle
is an abomination and blah,
blah,
and it is a choice and you could have
chosen to live another way,
but you're still a person and you're a
flawed person and you've made a
difficult choice and maybe you can come
back around.
I think that there's something that
really speaks to the core of the
structure of belief that an atheist,
as somebody who actively rejects the
foundation of what matters to these
people and and that act is so closely
tied to what they think of as the devil,
what they think of as evil,
what they think of as heresy.
All of these pure,
just irrationally fearful states.
It's apostasy.
It's,
it's what fuels Isis,
right?
It's,
it's worse than being a and Islamic
apostate.
It's worse than being a Christian
It's being an atheist,
right?
It's the ultimate.
It's the ultimate apostasy and I think
that that's really where it comes from
and because of that historically
generation generation,
I think we get a bad rap.
So you've got some people who are such
deep believers that there's no way
they're going to come around to it and
then you've got other people who just
equate the word atheism with like,
I dunno,
just like bad stuff.
Like they're criminals.
They're,
they're just like bad dudes.
Right?
So I want to get
the new atheism.
Yeah.
What do you think the other piece of
this is?
That to me it seems like because an
atheist can come from any religious
background,
be any sex,
but sexuality,
any nationality,
all of those things that in a weird way
what they fear is that this group of
people is coming together using sort of
the best of all of us.
You know what I mean?
Like they like that.
They think that it's sorta like for gay
people there are gay people of every
nationality and ethnicity and religion
and all that,
and that's why there's so much richness,
I think in the gay community and I'm
starting to think that that's what
people fear about atheists to because
there's black atheist,
white atheist,
atheist.
Let's see.
This is something that I think intrinsic
in what you just said,
the gay community,
like the atheist community,
it exists.
It exists,
but not to the same extent because I
think there's something that's sort of
fundamental to being an atheist that
makes some people reject trying to find
community.
The whole point is that we're not a
church.
The whole point is that we just don't
believe.
It's not that we all believed the same
thing is that we have a lack of belief
and I think that by definition that
makes some people feel like we don't
need to band together.
There is no common thread here.
It's just the default state.
All right,
so that's exactly where I wanted to go
with this because new atheist,
that seems to be the new thing.
So do you have a definition for new
atheist?
I can,
I can sort of tell you what I think,
but
I dunno.
I mean I think the new atheist is a term
that's often used by non new atheist,
so it's sort of a derogatory term.
So I'm not really sure how to define it
because it seems like from the outside
people apply that label.
Who knows?
Maybe I'm a new atheist.
I don't know.
I do know that the term firebrand
atheist is one that's actually kind of
um,
welcome within that community.
So David Silverman,
who was president of American atheist,
he has a new book coming out.
I actually wrote the foreword to his
book,
which is really funny because he's a
hardcore firebrand atheist and I'm like,
not at all.
But I liked that he is one because I
think it takes all types.
Right.
Firebrand though.
You mean like really outspoken?
Oh yeah.
Like he doesn't think you can be an
atheist Jew,
right?
Like he thinks you need to drop the
juice I because how can you be both an
atheist energy or you have to,
you know,
hold onto your atheist values and you
have to be very open about it.
Like we talked about this at length on
my podcast and I'm like,
of course you can be an atheist,
Sam Harris last week,
who's the one of the biggest alias.
I know that,
that barely makes any sense.
So aps,
so it doesn't believe in God,
but yeah,
I mean one of my best friends is an
atheist Jew and I get it like,
and he's Super Jewish and super atheist.
Um,
and so I'm not a firebrand atheist.
I am really kind of accepting of
people's religious beliefs.
And I think that we need a spectrum of
more secular values if we want to move
the goalpost.
But I think it's important that there
are firebrand atheist.
The same way that I think that it's
important that when you look at
feminism,
that there are men who hold onto
feminist ideals,
that there are women who are out loud
and proud and in front of the line
talking about it,
and then there are women who act in a
feminist way,
but who don't make it their mission to
always be that feminist.
Same thing with black lives matter.
Across the spectrum.
You need the people that are out in
front that are,
that are being loud,
that are making sure that people pay
attention to this movement,
but you also need the people who quietly
live their lives that way every day.
It's almost like we should have a broad
spectrum of different things and can all
still get along.
And exactly and the truth is if you have
atheists have all these different
flavors,
then I think that you're going to see
more people being affected.
More people that are afraid to come out
saying that person is just like me.
Or I see myself in that person and I can
look at them as a role model.
If we were all one flavor.
We would turn off a huge section of the
and I think to sort of wrap this up,
I think that's sort of the people that
are.
Unfortunately it happens to be a lot of
people on the left that had been
attacking new atheist.
My friend Kyle Kalinsky said that a new
atheist to him,
it's just an atheist that finally saying
I'm an atheist because atheist used to
have to just not say anything.
It's true.
And when I see these people on the left
attacking new atheist as if new atheists
have some set of beliefs,
all they have is this one thing in
common,
which is not belief,
not,
not a bigger sense.
And I,
you know,
I remember dating somebody a previously
who I think was a little confused about
my atheism but was probably agnostic
himself and I remember him saying
something about like,
I just don't understand why you have to
be so public about it.
I don't understand.
It's a private matter.
Why are you always.
And it's,
it's such a double standard.
He's like,
are you kidding me?
Religious people are like the most
public people about their religion.
And the fact that I want to say vocally,
I'm an atheist,
I don't believe in God.
I don't factor God into my decision
making.
I don't believe in any afterlife.
I don't believe in anything
supernatural.
I'm a science based,
evidence based thinker.
The reason I do that is because then if
I continue to live my life the way that
I hope I'm living in a moral way,
in an upstanding way,
then people can look and go,
oh,
that's what an atheist looks like.
Oh,
I've been really inspired the last
couple of weeks and I've been noticing
this over probably about six months or
so.
I sense a real awakening by secular
people,
not just atheist.
I mean people that are secular and that
they can have whatever belief that they
want,
but they want our public space,
our politics,
and our public life to have nothing to
do with religion.
Do you,
do you sense this?
Please tell me.
Yes.
That there's been some kind of
awakening.
So like constitutionalist.
So like people who are coming back
around to 250 years ago.
Yes.
No,
I definitely think so.
I think that it,
it does come from more people being
willing to say that they're
nonreligious.
It's the largest growing minority in the
country and even though people who self
identify as atheist or shield though
most hated group and trusted less than
rapists,
just totally crazy.
People who are not religious are growing
in numbers and I think they're growing
in solidarity and even religious people
who are saying are standing up for a
secular values and saying,
we need to promote a separation of
church and state and we need to move
away from the Christian privilege.
That is underlied our political
structure for way too long now.
Does it always strike you as odd that it
seems to me the religious right.
On one hand they always scream about
separation of church and state and then
they're the same ones that are always
pushing religion into the conversation.
Did it really scream of etc.
I guess they do.
I don't want to listen to them very
much.
You something real quick.
Something like kim davis and huckabee
where he was telling people that she
shouldn't abide by a law that she
doesn't believe in.
Actually,
I guess that
combining church and state,
I was given them a little bit.
Just a quick aside with this whole kim
davis,
why do people care?
It's just like this is like the plane
crash over and over and over,
right?
Like this has really no bearing on and
if anything,
this one woman is emblematic of how much
this movement is dying.
You know,
the fact that there's only one person
that they can point to and that
everybody's rallying around her and it's
a joke.
It's become such an eye roll and it to
me it's actually a good thing because
it's showing me that it's becoming more
and more marginalized and we don't have
to take them serious.
Yeah.
You know,
I completely agree.
I think I've sent two tweets on the
whole kim davis thing,
which normally it would be like one of
my wheel house thing,
but it seems to me it's like we've won
this one.
We've won,
right?
There's nothing that mike huckabee can
do to reverse this.
Even if god forbid he became president.
I say that with you already.
He won't
himself.
Like he's doubling down on a nonissue
that's embarrassing,
that it's laughable and I think that the
more that we put her in the spotlight
and the more that we do the wall to wall
cnn coverage about her,
the more it gives this false sense of
legitimacy that just doesn't exist.
Right.
It's like the media is blowing it up to
be this thing where actuallY the average
person is like,
you know what,
this,
this is a dying dinosaur,
right?
Yeah,
she is.
She's a monologue joke.
that's all she is.
You know.
So one more on this sort of broad topic.
Um,
so again,
I had,
I had sam on last week and it's been
really interesting for me to see what
happens when someone with a background
in science gets involved in politics.
And I almost think that the,
if I have one critique of sam,
it would be that he's placed himself in
this really precarious position out of
his own bravery.
And as he said,
it was at huge cost to him probably
personally and professionally,
I would imagine.
Um,
do you think it's hard for scientists or
should people have a science background
get involved in the political debate
because it seems he's two.
He in a lot of wayS,
he's too smart to be talking about the
way we talk about politics because
politics is so dumbed down.
I eat.
Donald trump is leading in the
republican party
and it's a binary,
right?
There's no room for nuance and political
debate,
especially not in the eight second sound
bytes that we've grown use to and
political media.
I don't know.
I'm of two minds about this.
So I am a cohost on the sKeptic's guide
to the universe,
which is a popular science podcasts that
really celebrates skepticism,
eviDenced based thinking,
debunking medical quackery and things
like that.
And the host,
steven novella is,
you know,
a renowned neuroscientist and a renowned
skeptic and He has an edit.
He has made an editorial decision on
this show over the past 10 years,
which I just joined like two months ago,
that we don't discuss politics,
that that's not relevant to the
scientific conversations.
Now on my podcast,
I talk about politics all the time
because I think that science is not just
a topic that you study.
It's not just facts and figures in a
textbook,
but it's a way of thinking and it's a
way of utilizing the principles of the
scientific method and looking at
evidence in order to make informed
decisions.
And so for me,
scientific thinking is the foundation of
politics and if we could start moving
into,
um,
into kind of a direction where this
country is governed based on evidence
and not based on as cold bear calls it
truthiness,
which is so often what we do.
Legislation passed because it gives you
a gut check,
right?
Or because there's pork or you know,
all those other reasons,
financial incentives and things like
that.
But so often we make strong legislative
decisions where there is evidence
available to us and we don't base it on
the evidence.
And I think that if we started moving
more in that direction,
we'd have a much more functional
government and definitely a more
functional economy.
And so I would like to see more
scientists moving into the political
arena.
But I can see why it would be
disconcerting if you are a functioning
university scientists because you also
oftentimes receive federal money.
And so then things start to get a little
bit confusing about where your
allegiance lies.
Now,
sam is not a university scientist.
He was a trained academic,
but it doesn't work as an academic.
He's an author.
He does political punditry now.
I mean,
it's part of his job and I applaud him
for that even though he's on hit list.
I'm sure he's on hitlist because of
this,
you know,
it's a choice that he made and I think
it's a really brave choice.
Um,
but yeah,
I have no doubt he's on hitlist.
Yeah,
there's like feed from today.
It's control.
So gmos,
we talked about gmos before.
Can you give me like a five minute sort
of gmo one one you say you just say gmo.
People freak out.
They go monsanto and everyone goes.
Yeah.
And lately there's this added confusion
because a scientist who I've interviewed
many times,
multiple platforms named kevin folta has
been in the news a lot because of a foya
requests that revealed some things that
people didn't want to see.
I'm mostly things that he never denied
anyway,
but,
um,
and it wasn't a lot of money that he got
and all that.
But thAt's a whole other ethics get
complicated.
um,
but,
but regardless of that,
if we're going to talk about the core of
gmos,
these other conversations really are
irrelevant to this core conversation.
Literally one.
Oh sure.
No.
If you don't know anything about.
So what is a gmo?
Well,
technIcally the word genetically
modified organism could refer to
anything,
any organism,
anything that's alive in which the genes
have been modified.
So basically breeding two plants
together to try and get a desired trait
is technically gmo.
Now that's not how we casually use the
word anymore.
We usually use the term gmo to actually
refer to transgenic organism.
So these are organisms where they
weren't selectively bred for particular
traits,
but there was actually a transgene that
was inserted.
We've gotten into the laboratory,
we've tested and we found these genetic
markers,
these areas where we can do something to
the plant.
Generally we're talking about plants.
There are some animals that are up for
fda approval like salmon,
but generally we're talking about plants
and scientists will say,
for example,
this is a big one right now.
Citrus greening is wiping out oranges in
Florida,
wiping them out.
They're all really sick.
It's getting harder and harder to get
fresh oranges and this is a problem that
they don't see going away.
Can we make oranges that are resistant
to this disease?
Because if we don't,
we may not have oranges anymore.
So the scIentists work very hard to go
into the genome to try and understand
all of these different genes within the
plant and try and modify them in a
certain way.
Sometimes it involves taking a gene from
another plant and inserting it.
Sometimes it involves turning a gene on,
silencing the gene,
making a gene do something that maybe it
wouldn't have done unless it was under
pressure.
Um,
there's a lot of different ways that you
can genetically modify a plant,
but that's the things we've done for a
long time for all kinds of different
plants.
Oh yeah.
And there are literally thousands of
research versions of gmos,
but there are very few gmos that are on
the market and I think that's another
big misconception.
People you'll see,
you know,
labels on crazy stuff,
like you'll see labels on potatoes that
are like gmo free and it's like,
well yeah,
because there's no such thing as a gmo,
but they're not modifying it to stop
either bugs from eating.
I mean they are in the lab but you can't
buy it yet.
So the thing is the only crops that are
available are mostly big ag crops.
So corn is genetically modified.
Probably most of the corn that you eat.
Soybeans,
sugar beets.
I'm papaya is genetically modified.
Genetically modified.
Apple Just came on the market or it's
about to,
um,
I think it's the okinawa apple at that
end.
It doesn't brown.
You can take a bite out of it.
Depended on the table and the ground.
It's pretty cool.
Did you try it?
It tastes like an apple gross and weird.
I did not.
We,
you know,
you've eaten a lot of gmos your day and
I don't see any appendages that aren't
supposed to be there.
All right.
So,
so from that very sort of simplistic
explanation of what gmos are,
why do so many people hate gmos because
people are afraid of what they don't
understand and there's a lot of
misinformation out there and so there
are some legitimate concerns when it
comes to environmental consequences.
I think probably the most legitimate
concern when it comes to gmos is the
what is a normal outcome of evolution,
and I use the example of super bugs with
antibiotics because I think it's a good
analogy.
so when we take antibiotics,
we actually induce resistance in the
bugs that can infect us and now there
are whole classes of bugs that are
resistant to those antibiotics.
Just like in gmo plants,
when you alter them to resist certain
pests or to resist.
I'm mostly with the past.
When you alter them to resist those
pests,
you may have new pests that devolve,
that evolve,
a resistance to that resistance.
You see it a little bit with weeds too,
liKe the glyphosate argument,
which is roundup.
People are really scared of roundup.
Bt is more the pes thing anD the
glyphosate is more of the weed thing and
people sometimes mix those things up.
That's sort of where monsanto gets
involved.
But we were talking about cover that
another time.
sure,
sure.
we're talking about,
you know,
the potential for super weeds to grow
because these plants are,
um,
are helping them grow.
Uh,
it's,
it's a natural process and it doesn't
just happen in gm.
It happens anytime that you're doing
large scale agriculture.
And so I like to say to people,
you know,
would you want to take all the
antibiotics off the market because
they're making antibiotic resistance?
No,
we need to be smarter about how we use
them and we need to come up wIth new
antibiotics.
And so what scientists are actually
doing is they're trying to figure out
new and better ways to improve
resistance to these different bugs.
Let's say that there is a,
um,
a pesticide inside of a plant and the
bug,
it develops resistance to that
pesticide.
Well,
if you actually alter that plant in two
ways,
now you have two lines of defense
against this bug.
It's statistically very unlikely that
you'll get a mutation in that bug
against both of those lines of
resistance.
So now you can have a resistant plant
and you're less likely to see resistance
occurring in the bug.
So,
you know,
scientists are always trying to keep one
step ahead of nature and these are the
biggest problems that we're seeing with
genetic modification.
A lot of the problems that people think
are happening with genetic modification,
cancer,
you know,
health problems,
what's a big one,
seeds blowing into another field and
getting sued for it.
Um,
suicides in India,
none of these are substantiated,
none of them.
The science shows time and time again
that these are not real concerns.
And if you actually do dig into the case
law and you actually do try and
understand what has happened legally in
these situations,
most of those lawsuits with the big ag
companies involve people storing,
which is technically against the law.
Now,
if you have a problem with,
you know,
patenting a c right?
Again,
it's a whole lot
if you have a problem with large scale
agribusiness and you have a problem with
the way that we dry out the land by only
farming a very particular crop,
I get that.
But that has nothing to do with genetic
modification.
And I think we often conflate the issue.
Yes,
the topic of abortion never seems to go
away.
And I wanted to talk to you as someone
of science and uh,
as an atheist who obviously has no
morals,
how do you negotiate this?
Because,
uh,
it seems to be the people on the left,
when they talk about abortion,
they make it sound like everyone on the
right hates women and that they want to
control women.
And when people on the right talk about
it,
they make it sound like everyone on the
left hates babies.
That's right.
And neither one of those things.
That's very obvious.
So how do you,
as someone that comes to conclusions
based on science,
how do you navigate the sort of ethical.
I assume you're pro choice,
but actually I'm just assuming that,
but is that.
How do you then as someone that's pro
choice believes in edit and it's in
science,
how do you decide where like do you
think that it should be a two month cut
off for an abortion?
Where do you,
where do you come up with that as
someone that isn't coming from the
religious angle,
but it's coming from the science based
angle.
I'd say abortion should be legal up
until 12 years old.
Pro like until the brain is fully known,
I'm actually,
that'd be more like 25 that's going to
take off.
You know,
it's funny because I am an evidence
based thinker.
I try to be an evidence based thinker
and a skeptical thinker and I try to
listen to the science first and then
make my political decisions based on
that.
So I am liberal,
I am left wing,
I am progressive.
I think it's easy to paint me in,
but I'm also super provax mandatory
vaccinations.
I'm pro gmo is,
which is.
It's usually a more conservative
viewpoint,
so sometimes it's hard to put me in a
box.
Now I'm.
I'm not pro life.
I am proud life.
I hate that term.
It makes it sound like I'm not.
I'm,
I am choice not because it's,
it's partially because of the science
and it's partially because I'm not
religious and I think that a lot of pro
life ideology comes purely from religion
and once you take religion out of the
equation,
it becomes a much more nuanced and
complicated topic.
I am pro choice,
meaning that I don't think that if a
woman wants to have an abortion,
she shouldn't be able to and I don't
think that if a woman wants to keep her
baby,
she should be coerced to have an
abortion.
I think that a woman should be able to
make a decision based on her own body
and in my view,
which may sound kind of extreme until
that baby is born.
It's hers,
it's her body.
Right?
So I,
I agree with you.
I guess up untiL that point,
I'm absolutely pro choice but,
but uh,
but a week before the birth,
I mean,
yeah,
I know that gets into your straw man
argument because it doesn't happen.
It's like the,
it's like the voter id stuff,
you know,
like old voter fraud.
We got to be careful about that.
Women don't carry babies to a week,
determine the goal.
I think I'm gonna lose this baby
facebook,
but so at three months when the baby now
has features and you know,
all of these things,
and I guess this is the slippery slope
up to this point.
It's
legal first and second trimester
abortions are legal.
And I think that you have to look at all
this is the thing,
when you're writing laws,
we have to think about not just the
obvious cases but the abberant cases.
This is why writing legislation is
actually a very,
you know,
it's a nuanced and artistic endeavor and
especially within when you look at how
you defend laws in the courts,
right?
When you look at case law,
it's complicated because we have to
fully understand all of the times when
the,
when the laws can be misused or
misinterpreted and there are cases,
for example,
where a woman does not know that she is
pregnant until well into her pregnancy
and I think you do have to take that
into consideration.
There are cases in which women are
victims of coercion or abuse or
sometimes it is more nuanced than that.
Maybe they feel pressure from their
husband,
their boyfriend or a member of society
to have a baby and they don't realize
until later that they do have these
options.
Maybe they fall on financially difficult
times.
Maybe they find out that there's a,
you know,
some sort of genetic abnormality and the
baby and that they don't have the means
to raise that baby.
And I think that all of those really
complicated,
really emotional personal questions have
to be taken into account.
I want to say,
and it may be,
it's easy for me to say because I don't
have kids,
but the woman is the vessel and she is
carrying this child and until the child
comes out of her,
it is her body is her choice and they
are her rights and I do think that it's
a complicated topic and I think that
that's why it's important that we do
talk about it
and I,
I almost regret having said the part
about the one week before birth because
I know it is a straw man and it does.
It's not something that happens,
but I think there's something
interesting about the when is it really
a feasible life thing that and obviously
we can't resolve that
and I think that we have to think about
every possible option because even
religious people you'll,
you'll find that.
Whereas they would be appalled if they
got knocked out and had an abortion.
They might go get ivf,
which some religions don't even allow
that,
but they might get ivf and of course
they're going to do selective reduction
during ivf.
Is that not abortion in the interview?
I mean,
it's very complicated because,
you know,
sometimes you do ivf and like five of
them stick and then you turn into john
and kate plus eight.
So I guess the most extreme religious
people even in those cases,
look at,
look at a babY as a blessing from god.
It's almost like people pick and choose
when to believe in religion.
So,
uh,
one more for you.
Um,
what I want to do with all these
interviews is sort of end on a very
personal note and we actually started on
a personal note because you talked about
leaving the church and very personal
things related to atheism.
So you have talked about your,
a battle or struggle with depression
pretty,
pretty vocally.
Um,
but I,
I know you pretty well over the last
three years.
It's not something that we talk about a
lot privately and yeah,
it's not actually well in that way.
I know you to be totally like happy and
well adjusted.
Whatever you struggle with depression.
Yeah.
Really good actors.
They are,
it's a coping mechanism that they
develop.
And that's not to say that like every
day of my life I'm pretending to be
happy because I experience joy and I
experience happiness on a regular basis.
I'm also in treatment and I take
medication every day.
And that has made a huge difference.
there have been periods of my life where
if you had seen me,
which I would not have allowed you to
see me because I was very private,
you know,
again,
we come up with our strategies and we
come up with our coping mechanisms.
If we had been in a position where you
had seen me at my lowest of lows,
um,
yeah,
you wouldn't be saying the same thing.
And so I think that that's a common
experience for people who struggle with
depression.
There's a private side of your
depression and then there's a public
face if you're willing to have one,
which not many people are.
And I completely understand that.
Um,
I personally feel like I have a
responsibility as somebody who has a bit
of,
um,
you know,
people tweet me,
facebook,
me,
they,
you know,
some people know that I exist and I,
and I've noticed that when I do talk
about this,
the feedback that I get is really,
um,
it just makes me feel good.
It makes me feel good to know how many
people are out there who are struggling
with this and don't see that a lot of
people are talking about it publicly.
So because of that,
I feel a real obligation to do it.
Is it depressing?
I guess that's an odd choice.
Depression.
Depressing.
Is it depressing to you?
Or disconcerting,
I suppose would be a better word that we
don't really have a mental health
discussion in this country anymore.
I feel like maybe five years ago we
actually did a little bit.
People talked about a little bit and
now,
and I think it was around when the
shooting started really,
but I don't think we do anymore with the
shootings were not,
were not immediately go into the gun
thing and that's obviously we need to
have that discussion,
but I worry that the mental health,
the thing is like escape goat for the
gun advocates so you have the gun nutter
butters and are like,
but it's not because of gone,
it's because he was mentally ill and he
shouldn't have gotten.
I'm not saying that that's not also a
very important conversation to have,
but just like we should be having
conversations about gun control
when we're not in crisis.
You know,
the same thing.
Like when you're having like sexual
problems at home,
probably not a good idea to talk about
them when you're both like naked and
like it's better to wait until it's a
more calm situation.
He said,
oh,
okay.
Sorry I didn't run.
Wasn't really into it or I couldn't get
it up or whatever it was going on that
it's a safe
time to talk about it.
I think it's the same thing when it
comes to both gun control and mental
health,
like we should be talking about this in
the light and in the dark because it's
not really that helpful when we're doing
it only in crisis and I think it also
elevates and ignores the day to day
struggles that people have.
You know,
depression is a massive illness and it's
a biological illness and it's an illness
that destroys lives and it is so
treatable.
The problem is that,
you know,
in this country especially,
I think with the older set,
we are getting better just like with
coming out as atheist.
We aren't getting better with the
younger people.
Erasing that stigma and being more
comfortable talking about it.
The problem is we still treat
psychiatric illnesses like,
like disorders of will,
and that's,
that's a fundamental hurdle that we have
to get past that somehow you can will
yourself out of it.
That somehow you can change your
patterns of thInking.
Just think more positively.
Just do that and you'll be.
Well,
it's because people don't understand the
biological basis of these issues and
we've never treated depression.
For example,
the same way that we've treated
diabetes,
you would never shame somebody into
needing insulin.
Right?
But we do.
We shame people who take
antidepressants.
We shame people who have to take
psychiatric medication and that's just a
huge bummer and I hate to see young kids
either being scared away for it or
feeling like they're not allowed,
are scared away from it.
I'm sorry.
Or feeling like they're not allowed to
be honest with themselves and older
people too.
my father,
my father went through a depressive
episode and my father has struggled with
some things and I remember when he
finally told me when I was struggling
myself,
it was so meaningful for me.
It helped me so much.
Oh,
oh.
So much has explained.
And then he became this confidant and I
could talk to them about it,
but I had no idea what he was going
through it because he lives a
generation.
It's like a self fulfilling prophecy.
Almost the shame then just continues the
cycle.
Meanwhile you hear it from your father
and that it probably makes you feel
better in,
in who you are.
Well,
and the thing,
I mean,
what you just said is so important.
There's this negative feedback when
you're depressed,
like actually physically experiencing a
depressive episode,
such a big portion of that is guilt and
shame and to have an added layer of
guilt and shame that comes from society,
not understanding your depression and
then having to carry the guilt of being
depressed while you're depressed.
It's insane.
It's impossible.
And so I think the more that we become
open about it and the more that we
celebrate all of our differences and our
quirks and the more that we understand
that going to therapy,
it's like something that a lot more
people should probably do.
And um,
and,
and being okay with that and being okay
with the fact that we all have our
issues,
you know what I mean?
And we all struggle and I think it makes
us richer and it makes us more
interesting and it makes us more human.
Um,
I don't know.
That's the world I want to live in.
Yeah.
That's the world that want to live.
And I think we did a little talk therapy
here,
right?
How do you feel now?
It's
definitely not the same.
Might shrink.
Shrink would probably.
I'm not like to hear that.
This is a therapy session.
Well,
a camera or a worst part.
I'll tell you what.
That was a hell of an outro.
Alright.
Well cara,
of course.
He's one of my favorite people.
You can follow her.
It's carrie santa maria.com
at caris.
Santa maria on twitter.
Do you want to send them anywhere else?
That's good.
All right.
Thanks for watching everybody and we'll
do it again next week.